优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
請各位加一下
請各位先加個群
密碼4個8
有聽到聲音加個1
各位加一下,因為今天有在群裡面聊一些東西
待會我直接
開群給各位看
今天聊的
剛好在裡面
所以我今天
待會開群的內容給各位看
你們先加一下
那這個群是我們上次的那個
就是
新邁寧直播的討論群
那各位加一下
那我們
有在上面呢
討論一些今天的案例
我今天在裡面呢
在裡面呢 剛好有
有
有在上面聊一些
好
來
來 給各位看一下這個群今天聊的
今天聊 我找一下找一下
找一下
老花越來越嚴重了
看股票看久了 老花變嚴重
哎呦
加了沒
欸 等一下
這個
各位先加一下這個密碼4個8喔
密碼4個8
密碼4個8 各位先加一下我看一下欸 怎麼還沒有欸這個要審核啊應該密碼4個8直接可以進來
看一下
我還沒看到那個人家加進來
可以直接進來嗎
各位呢先加一下喔
先加一下這個群,待會有些東西給各位看
等一下 我站一下
打開
喔 西班牙討論群
欸對啊沒錯
欸 有有有有有
哇 有人加進來了
好 那給各位看一下喔
這個 嗯 先來看一下
這個討論群
我今天在上面PO的啦
所以 所以我就呢
給各位看一下
今天剛好來錄影的時候呢
欸
好 這邊齁 這裡齁
我今天在上面呢 就聊一下這個東西啊
這個雙刀
那雙刀 我就說男星配真不錯
那各位看一下喔 這是我們一個
處置的軟體啦 處置軟體
那我前兩天呢 就有說我會去做一個
空心心買藍店
再跟各位講一次
空星星買南電
然後今天早上開盤喔
這個南電還往上衝
那星星是往下殺的
南電往上衝星星往下殺
所以我今天早上呢
我是這個
把南電賣掉
因為我們是空星星買南電
那我把南電賣掉
把南電賣掉
然後買星星
今天有去買星星
把南電賣掉
因為星星今天一早跌很慘啊
所以買星星空藍店
各位來看一下喔
今天一早這個
這個雙刀戰法
很有趣喔
因為這兩個是一個
相關係數超級高的股票
各位看一下
他們相似度有98%
那星星跟藍店不用說了啦
大家都知道他們很相關嘛對不對
你也知道他很相關
星星藍店緊碩嘛對不對
所以這邊的交易呢
我是空星星買藍店
來做這個雙刀
好那詳細的一些
呃做法跟解說我們在禮拜四哈禮拜四有個高升率處置客呢我們在跟各位講一下禮拜四有高升率儲置課再跟各位講那我除了做這一組交易以外呢我家有做另外一組交易
我有在這邊討論
來我有做這組交易把它關掉一下
關掉一下這裡啊我有做這組交易
這邊
我今天呢還有做一個
那个买波若薇
空还语
买波若薇空还语
我做这组交易
那为什么买波若薇空还语
礼拜四在跟各位好好讲
我先给各位看对当单
这个是康儿心心传的对当单
康儿心心传
那各位
那个他的时间点
这个时间跟你的成交时间会不一样
因为他的时间是他们key in的时间
key in
他们
他們是用自己手key in的 我每次都打電話跟他講說你可不可以key快一點
因為你不key快一點 我都不曉得我成交什麼
所以這個他們手key in的
那我今天就有去買3163 用抗星賺買 因為他20分鐘了
打電話跟他買比較方便
好
20分鐘呢 買在這個位置 我買750
買這750這個位置
這裡啊
這裡有段750的
有一段750 我應該是買到
這兩盤不知道哪一盤
這兩盤都買得到
那為什麼買他呢
呃 事實上就是我
我是用這張表去看的
我用這張表去看的
因為我覺得波羅威
波羅威跟那個
再來看一下
我的雙刀戰法
再來
來 我的雙刀戰法
來 各位呢
我們來看一下我們的處置坐牢中
處置坐牢中
這個波羅威蠻值得一買的啦
因為這處置股呢
這裡就算是跌蠻多的
波羅威因為漲上來
本來他排在前幾名
本來他也是跌很多的
那尾盤突然急拉上來
你買750欸
七百五買10張 蠻爽的
10張 後來我賣在這個點
這點有賣掉
他入金有券
康爾有讓我賣掉了
康爾有讓我賣掉
那怎麼賣的呢 反正他們有庫存他們就可以處理
好
那我從這裡找的啦 因為他是這個
波若薇跟
跟環宇吼 因為
因為環宇他
他未來也是有機會被灌
唉唷 等一下
糟糕 這也沒有 哈哈
這裡沒有環宇
那我是用我的錶去找的
這裡
哎等一下
這沒有環雨哦
把他們當作是一國的勒
哎
所以
弄到這邊來
我來看一下我的
我的雙刀戰法
啊我用雙刀戰法本來就配到
因為盤中還有看一下這個
這張表
誤會了
奇怪怎麼沒有配到
可是不見了
好這裡
總表
這裡
波若薇跟環宇
喔這邊
這裡啊
這邊有張表喔
這裡
哦
今天我看他這個這個紙喔反正這紙他掉很多啊
這紙掉很多奇怪我今天盤中是看到這裡了怎麼現在不見了
還是我找不到
奇怪了
找不到我的懷語
啊我今天就做波羅威跟懷語喔
我空了因為我覺得這兩個蠻類似的喔
我空了這個
好
空了
在這裏看
買的波羅威
然後這邊的空了還語
然後還語被嘎掌停
那還語被嘎掌停的時候其實
波羅威的
漲幅還比還語多了
所以這整組的也是
在當時是小賺的
在當時小賺的
好
處刺
這個我跟各位講
嗯
這個我給各位看一下畫面給各位看因為這個能不能當充其實要康和那邊可以解決
給各位看一下畫面
我先看一下康和的畫面
開完之後給各位看
這是康和新金賺
成交我看一下成交有沒有
历史對賬單 看一下
來來我把這畫面拿下來
給各位看
歷史對賬單
歷史對賬單 不曉得各位有沒有看過
喔 心金賺的對賬單
來
嗯
波羅威我賣掉了
那能不能賣齁 其實
不一定可以賣
因為其實你假如有資有卷 當然可以賣
就是都要入金啦
兩邊都要入金
然後想辦法沖掉
不過他們的帳是幫我沖掉
我這邊是賣827.5
827.5這個他們先預扣那個
預扣成本
預扣成本應該就只要扣一個那個那個什麼東西
交易稅
是這樣子
所以呢他應該是算這個價格
這個價格啦
830嘛
然後扣2.5
所以是這個
好啦
所以對賬單就這樣子啦
反正我就是衝掉了
這邊衝掉10張
這個
這邊
衝掉10張
對賬單都給各位看了 就這樣
好
這是我的對賬單
一般處置是不能衝的
是跟各位講一般處置不能衝的
因為那個基本上要有券
還要簽入金
所以通常是
不能衝的
好所以這個
這個處置真的很有意思啦
齁
處置很有意思
歡迎各位呢先加一下這個群
齁
你先加這個群齁
我們不定時的會在上面分享一下
齁
不定時在上面分享一下我們的做法
但是我們通常是盤後才分享
我們不會盤中分享
盤中分享怕影響行情啊
齁
所以盤後分享
我三天前本來是買電空心
齁
三天前本來是買電空心啊
買南電空心心
我現在反過來
現在反過來
欸 三天前欸三天前買電空心我們來看一下來看一下各位來看一下這雙刀奇怪喔我的團羽今天早上有看到啊
不知道怎麼不見
來
各位看我們這雙刀
欸欸欸欸
來這邊
喔三天前呢
他們的筆值啊
是1.04喔
喔這邊的筆值是什麼意思呢
我按一下
他會寫出來給你看
星星除以南電
三天前是星星比南電貴
1.04
現在是
南電比星星貴變0.94
你懂嗎
這很像那個台灣跟泰國的匯率一樣
台灣跟泰國匯率
以前台幣比泰國
比泰...泰豬貴
現在泰豬比台幣貴
對這很像嘛
這裡
三天前1.04嘛
啊外星星被關了
那現在變成那個
藍電比較貴
三天前吼
我空星星的時候
我空星買藍電
他們兩個差20塊
差20欸
星星比藍電貴20
啊你看現在
現在星星跟藍電差多少
三天前吼
各位你看
你看啊
我們用三天前給你看
沙鋼井
沙鋼整家3月19號3天前
3天前3月19號
有沒有 我看見沒有
欸 581欸
啊 藍店哪個欸
藍店哪個欸
561 差20塊
所以3天前你空欣欣買藍店
喔 這個3天我就說我要做這腳印
空欣欣買藍店
空星星買藍電對不對
差20塊啊
管他漲管他跌不用管嘛
你不用管今天
三天前星星是
今天星星低點剩多少
460差120塊
然後藍電呢
三天前546
今天一開百還有到
三天前562
今天還有到562最高點耶
5.62
所以你看這一組 你不厲害
空星星買藍店 厲不厲害
這個 這一組超厲害的這一組超厲害空星欣買人店新藍配這組很爽啊很爽的
好不好
這一組很爽的
那這一組你怕不怕
怕不怕
川普講什麼話
你有空單的人
昨天晚上看到川普說
已經
已經和解了
嚇到
這個尿出來
對不對
但是你做這組就不用怕了啊
對不對 做這組怕什麼
你有藍電多單 你是在怕什麼
對不對
你有藍電多單啊 你就不用怕
就是今天開盤藍電開高嘛 對不對
所以你有藍電多單
啊 假如萬一大碟咧
大碟你也不用怕啊 你有吸吸空單啊
對不對 是不是不用怕
所以我就今天呢 我就選擇了這個
我就選擇了
星星跟藍電配
還有波羅威跟環宇配
波羅威跟環宇配
波羅威跟環宇怎麼找不到
來偏差率什麼意思喔 我們講一下
這裡啊 偏差率很簡單啊
是這樣子喔 他們的比值
平均是0.93
0.93
然後現在是0.94
0.94就比0.93多一趴
這叫偏差率
3天前是多12%啦
3天前本來彼此在這邊嘛
那我就賭他會收斂啊
他果然也收斂
有沒有
賭他收斂果然收斂
這招太厲害
所以這招呢
就幫我度過了最近的
這一段過程啊
災難機會
好不好
最近這招超好用的
災難機會的時候就可以用了
好不好
災難機會你就可以好好使用
齁
就這樣子啊就這樣讀偏差就好了
所以很簡單喔
等一下我再看一下
奇怪了波羅威跑去哪
欸我知道了
來來來
原來在環宇這邊找
來出來了這裡
懷語波羅威 這裡
從懷語找
懷語波羅威 對呀
我想說懷語吧
你看這懷語這種樣子
他好意思 他現在
現在
大家都這麼空頭的 他好意思 有沒有
他好意思一個人在上軌 好意思嗎
那他也是一個 他也是得癌症的股票 處置癌
然後今天也第六款
哇 這邊第六款喔 啊這個是第幾款 第六款 差不多了
喔 在三天就可以了
比例怎麼抓 就
就那個啊
每個問比例的我都跟他講
比例怎麼抓非常簡單
表彰禁止是多少
那我就
我就做還語啊
來來來
來喔
雙刀戰法
我就對波羅威嘛
來各位看一下波羅威
來我們先來看一下筆直齁
這是環宇出於波羅位
喔
這是
這個環宇出於波羅位
然後呢
環宇是分子
他曾經啊
他曾經今天一早是多少你知道嗎
環宇出於波羅位喔
來給各位看一下
來你看一下我的環宇出於波羅位是多少
還以411
喔
波羅位750嗎
剛剛有這邊看了
對是不是750
411除以750
等於0.548
好
所以呢
我是在
均值0.51耶
我今天是在0.548空耶
我在0.548空
然後結果跌到0.47啊
手板剩0.47啊
我是空0.548嗎
我空0.548
手板是不是剩下0.47
你說這個好不好用
超好用
有沒有
我是0.54啊
手板0.47啊
這樣賺多少啊
這樣賺14%欸
你知道嗎為什麼賺14%
因為波羅威爾賺了快10%嘛
那懷疑賺4%嘛
14%一來一回就接了
你懂啊啊這不能隨便配好不好不要隨便配各位不要隨便配跟各位講不要賣賣啦你自己
要好好的
好好的認真上課好不好
認真上課
我們有一個
免費的課
高勝率處置策略線上
體驗課
喔
因為在做這個交易我覺得很有意思啦
喔 現在跟你講的交易都很有意思
對不對
這個
這是很有意思的一堂課
我來找一下那個
星星跟聯電的對賬單
因為前天有結
現在可以直接看我手機畫面
我覺得蠻方便的
我找一下
哎呀
星星跟聯電
我現在腦花嚴重了
新星跟南店
新跟南店我們上禮拜就有做
上禮拜就有做這個新星配南店
诶等一下
新星配南店有沒有結在我這張圖裡面呢
啊有有有
找到
這裡啊
這邊
欸這裡
上禮拜就有星星跟藍店啦
這邊
星星偏空嘛
藍店偏多嘛 偏多也賠錢啊
有些藍店今天才解掉
喔 有些藍店今天才解掉
喔 所以這個
這很有意思喔 那這值怎麼配
這你有跟著我在
今年年初上的課齁 我們大概就有提到
那我們現在高勝率處置策略呢
也會教啦 各位有興趣你可以報名
報名免費的
報名免費
郭吉他
林亞光聖有啊 林光我有做啊
林光我們之前做了
哇林光那個
那個賺更多
林光那個我們在講義裡面就有講
林亞光聖
我跟各位講 聯亞光聖喔
準備做光聖聯亞好啦今天聽直播的那個跟各位講之後我會找一天做光盛配聯亞
我看一下
我來看一下
光盛配聯亞
Yeah
有稍微翹起來了
喔這邊有稍微翹起來了
來來來
看一下光盛配聯亞
就稍微翹起來
喔
這個是
連光配
這邊我們之後會有機會來做
喔
之後有機會來做啊
有機會來做這個
連亞配光聲
好啦
會早時間來做啦
欸這早安提
波羅威找不到 配不到還女我不曉得欸
對啊我就
還女配得到波羅威
波羅威配不到還女欸
這個要我再跟那個那個那個那個那個講一下
我再跟那個
理財你才幫我講一下怎麼會找不到呢
好這個很好用啊齁這個歡迎各位
歡迎各位好好的學這堂歌
這堂歌是太有用了好不好
你就好好的玩雙刀啦雙刀真的很好玩齁很好玩
喔欸
記憶體類股秋天了齁這我們在高雄出口股也有跟各位講齁
記憶體類股齁 再這樣下去很有可能怎麼樣
很有可能有些人的融資會出問題齁
來看一下
唉呦
哇 你看這邊融資有人追高點
這邊追高點
這個 我們來看一下齁 這個在
春夏秋冬裡面呢 這是一個純純的秋天齁
純純的秋天了 月線
下完 阻力賣 盤整
都快要入冬了 你知道嗎
都快要入冬了
萬王處置兩天就變20分沒有啦
那我處置兩天
處置三天啊 那我兩天
1 2 3 好不好
三天 好不好
這裡有三天啊
三天就來啊
光聖佩蓮雅
做多光聖嗎 不是
光聖佩蓮雅是
做空光聖
做空光聲
欸看一下
欸 又不是漲停嗎
這我記錯了找機會做空光聲欸他沒漲啊 等他漲停那天隔天我就做空光聲
瑞薰還在嗎 瑞薰我不在
松安哥賠彩 松安哥手滾出來
手滾出啦 手滾出的
不用替他擔心
來來來來來來來來來看一下看一下
哎呦 賠兩億 還好啦
兩億
對阿而言
不多啦
而且搞不好人家有會播啊對不對
搞不好會播到凱基耶
欸
應該沒有
凱基太北
欸
應該也不是
所以可能還在
可能還在
雙刀人用凝骨做完不行
因為你的
雙刀我們建議用期貨做啦
欸用期貨做才好好不好
槓桿開
開超多
欸2002去
不是我啊那不是我
不是我
我昨天沒出啊
2002不是我
喔
202啊
那又巨人那不是我啦
不奇怪好不好
不奇怪
華泰
華泰各位啊
華泰明天是
華泰各位不用太擔心了吧
那個
欸明天
明天第六天
各位你看一下明天華泰的CBS怎麼敲
華泰
只要這些
全鎮大戶沒有跑了 你不用太擔心了
好不好
喔
3481是哪一季啊
來 3481是哪一季呢
各位看一下這哪一季
看起來有點秋天了
喔 有點秋天喔
這有點秋天了 喔
威康就是處置回廣喔
這個還是一個
還是一個夏天形態
這個還沒有入球
喔 3042做頭
不會吧
不會啦
沒有啦
沒有做頭啦
從這邊看最高點下來才第一次而已啊
中探針他是一個處置回檔
處置回檔會是
回檔早埋點
反正處置回檔都是早埋點的啦
有沒有這種處置回檔都早埋點
這種第一次
創歷史高然後的回檔都早埋點
哦
华泰
哎 华泰 你
你買線股你要不要看人家那個買權證的好不好
買權證的都沒怕你就不用怕
來來來來來來來
藍屯哥
喔藍屯哥好不好
喔三銀就在賣了
哎呦
今天賣那麼多喔
怎麼了
欸有藍吞哥
沒說
沒說還不曉得今天賣那麼多
喔然後那個
呃
華文昌台中哥還沒賣掉
有華文昌賣那麼多難怪這麼弱
這是
喔
怡婷拉會找滿一點我覺得是欸
我覺得這些都是拉會找滿一點
只是他的籌碼比較爛
有沒有
答錯了
他們這兩個好像
3289叫一特 5289叫一頂
好 這次拉回找買一點
我說線型啊 籌碼是爛
比較爛 然後那個
雨簪
雨簪跟雨簪 雨簪的籌碼就漂亮多了
雨簪籌籌碼是非常漂亮
非常漂亮
2451也是浪子回頭
對啊 這也是浪子回頭
龍柱回頭啊
龍柱回頭好不好
我們這邊很多浪子回頭的通知啊
最近盤比較弱
浪子回頭通知很多
浪子回頭的通知就是回檔
喔回檔
來來來來
給各位看我們這邊
波羅威處置回檔後漲10%
他那個喔
波羅威本來是
儲置後跌10%
看到這訊號
波羅威咧
這麼大型的股票
儲置後跌10%
趕緊去買
然後呢
然後怎麼樣
然後就發生這事了
儲置回達後漲10%
漲10%趕快賣掉
喔 漲10%差不多
我對這種強反彈的漲10%我就很爽了漲10%就爽了 所以這邊呢這邊很多那個 反正你假如有看到處置回檔後漲10%我就很爽了漲10%就爽了所以這邊呢反正你假如有看到處置回檔後漲10%
那就是有訊號之後
然後呢後面有
有一個這個
哇這兩天盤很爛
一堆浪子回頭
有的有訊號之後呢
這個回檔後漲10%
這邊有一個趙賀
趙賀是處置回檔後漲10%
回檔後長10%
那個
明後天
只要盤變好
你就看到一堆
匹吉太來東山再起
東山再起
啊
嗯
記憶體我是覺得喔
記憶體類股我覺得只剩這幾個
處置股
還有可能有最後一拉
其他的都蠻弱的
都蠻弱的
來 我們直接看一下記憶體喔
這個夏天的記憶體
夏天記憶體
入秋了嘛
有沒有把他們弄在同一個族群啊
夏天的記憶體
入秋了
群聯
入秋了好不好
主力賣 這種任何反彈都是找
任何反彈 隔日充的隔天都是找空點的
都是找空點的
再跟各位講一次
任何反彈 隔日沖的隔天都找空點
那浪子會到裡面怎麼找
會有可能18的 籌碼好的
籌碼好的最有可能是他
喔
我覺得宇瞻有機會啦
各位我覺得宇瞻有機會
因為他是籌碼好的阿
你看他主力沒賣阿 我覺得他有機會
我們家
喔真的鳥是很吵
每年都這個三四月開始吵
要吵一個月
他在求我
很吵
好
處置股喔 望宏是有機會的喔
因為望宏是創高後的回檔
我覺得望宏還有機會
但是很多股票呢 都有一點做頭了
金曹科呢 他還有機會反彈一下
反正一下也是會做頭
然後平安這個不行了
我會剛剛 呃 還有機會翻
還有 還有右肩啦
好不好 還有右肩
右邊的肩喔 做頭嘛那這是左肩啊那還有一個右尖他們還有機會有個右尖那黃黃店已經做完了
這感覺已經是個三尊頭了
我不知道幾尊
這是五尊嗎
五尊頭
竹力也在賣
宇山寺還有機會喔 宇山寺
這個型態還有機會
華東純純沒救
好不好
上次有人問說
華東小哥華東會不會變強
華東要怎麼樣的
你想太多
好不好
你不要想那麼多
聲貿轉讓
看到沒有
17500張
一般交易
這華東
看到沒有華東17500張
你不要想太多啦 你以為這邊籌碼會變好啊
董事都告訴你要賣的啊 對不對
董事告訴你要賣的
那你在那邊 你覺得他會好啊 他是人多好
對不對
他怎麼覺得多好
呦 等一下
欸
啊我還敦南咧
我還沒錢啊 喔這裡這裡
國海敦南咧
對不對 國外遁難還在
你看 呃
喔 現在 國外遁難 囤了蠻多華東的喔
喔 報上又報下
喔 這就是散戶的宿命
散戶宿命
這一 很難啦 我覺得華東很難 好不好
華東很難 各位不要想太多
怡鼎很有機會喔
來 怡鼎是有機會的 各位
1400元今天我有搶到這個
這個跌停哎呦結果沒差多少
追牌跌殺下來
這有機會哦一定有機會
哦一定有機會
創建了也有機會哦
他們這個都有機會一個右肩的
右肩的逃命
利基電這看起來
蠻糟糕的
所以呢跟各位講
記憶體類股大概有七成的記憶體類股各位呢不用做太多期待
這七成的記憶體類股
任何
反彈
的隔天
有很多隔日充
的話
都是好空點
都是很好的賣點
都是很好賣點
記憶體類股看起來是這樣
好不好
記憶體類股看起來是怎樣
除了我剛剛講的那幾個處置的
現在我覺得就處置了記憶體類股
未來還有機會搶一下
其他的我覺得都沒啥
沒啥希望
看起來都沒啥希望
好
欸
不用害怕好不好
各位不用害怕
你現在叫你做多你也怕
叫你做空你也怕
你就好好地来学我们的处置策略
双刀战法
双刀
画得很清楚吗
处置策略双刀战法
就会教你怎么做
双刀
会教你怎么玩双刀
就怎么玩
完了你就不用擔心了啦
齁
你現在手上
手上那個
多空都有
就不用擔心
好不好
你手上
這個只有存多單你也很怕的
你也很怕的齁
你就要學好高勝率儲值勝率
這真的很有趣
很有趣
那我們是配合理財寶
有最近這一課啦
這課教各位懂
通常在教的那一段時間會不好做
因為太多人會跟你做一樣的方法
太多人跟你做一樣的方法
就是買的點就變貴
那賣的點就變便宜
對不對
那沒辦法
配合一下理財寶
理財寶也是有很多家庭要養
好
來
這個雙刀
真的蠻好玩的
來來來來
然後我們來看一下
一開始歡迎
各位加一下這幾個QR Code
啊這裡有
PressPlay的九折優惠券
啊各位有需要可以
掃一下
啊那 PPA呢我們每天呢都會有
文章影音
啊
影音文章還有
QA
每天都有
那各位有什麼問題呢
歡迎在上面問
啊歡迎在上面問
好
那這幾個QR Code呢
各位也可以加一下
這個光色島教育知識
YouTube教學影片
IG有一些當充的點位
IG呢當充的點位我沒有很喜歡
沒有很喜歡貼啦
為什麼因為
因為我們都喜歡做短空啊
有些人他就不喜歡人家空到他的股票
其實當充本來就短空勝率比較高
我們就一直在做一個勝率高的策略
但是有的人就不喜歡
不喜歡他的股票被空到
所以我就不好意思常貼
好 歡迎各位加一下
那我們就要這個
小哥討論群
不定期分享雙刀 贊碼跟資訊
我們是分享實戰成果啦
好不好 實戰成果分享一下
因為
跟你分享實戰成果嘛
你不要叫我
小哥你要不要實戰前分享
不行啊 那個叫代單啊
我們是
分享實戰的成果
然後告訴你know how
告訴你know how 告訴你為什麼這樣幹
告訴你
不是要代單好不好
盤頭分享一下
那有問題的
歡迎各位在上面聊天
多聊
那詐騙不要來好不好
你在
你只要在這個上面
看到有人
什麼跟你引導到另外一個群的
一律詐騙
好不好
再跟各位講
有人引導到別群的
一律詐騙
那你要
那裡面假如有人
號稱他全陣小哥
你要看有沒有
有沒有那個
皇冠
有皇冠才是
皇冠管理人才是
隨便其比照去年做
對啊 今年隨便很好玩
很好玩喔 因為友誼檔超好玩的
隨便其各在一講
好 那實際投資吧
各位有興趣的也歡迎
這個蠻多人
蠻多人訂的啊唉唷我最新的QR Code我看一下我看一下他有沒有給我最新QR Code
欸~~
這還沒有喔
欸?
這班他沒有給我QR Code
好啦 沒就算了
好 那我們的
最近呢有很多人齁
他仿冒
仿冒我去
我去加人家的那個
一堆人都會問我這個問題啊
小哥你有這個群組嗎
我說啊那個人不是私訊你
對不對
啊我的大頭貼都寫了我不會私訊你
喔
來來來來
這裡
這個喔
每次都有人來問這問題
來喔來
請問這個是您開的群組嗎
開的群組
有沒有
任命男勾勾 我跟小秘書沒空私訊你
你不覺得很奇怪嗎
這個詐騙已經染到那個這個土都不遮的
任命男勾勾 我跟小秘書沒空私訊你
我都寫了沒空私訊你了
那我還私訊你
你是
你動作我贏
對不對
我要私訊你
感謝追蹤有建立股票LINE群組有分享成股資訊
你可領取新選
這不做的你要加入嗎
你動作我贏
還要問你幾年次
好不好
還要問你什麼星座
還要問你什麼學期
對不對 你動作我贏
我是我贏你
我都在錄PP
都在錄理財達人秀
我剛才錄完理財達人秀回來
還要坐火車
對不對
我那麼閒
還要問你
你幾年次
相親欸 問你幾年次
每次有一堆人問
這不是一個人問 這常問
啊 常問
你看看我的大頭天都說不會失訊
其實大家都會有一個驚喜哎呀 小哥傳訊給我了還問我幾年次 會很開心
然後想想好像又是詐騙 只好來問我
我肯定是有一個 會緊張也詐騙
好 何先生開開玩笑
沒有對你有不敬的意思
然後春開玩笑 好不好
何明俊不要難過 春開玩笑
因為類似的問題太多了啦
類似問題太多了 我再找一下
欸每天都有人問欸
每天都有人問
你看來來來
來 又來了
同學有需要加入嗎
我是小哥的侄子 我要叫他故障
這真的 這是要叫我故障
我的 這樣子沒有別的群組嗎
嗯
然後就來問我說 故障那是真的嗎
呵呵 當然是假的
呵呵呵
喔 就這樣子
呵 當然是假的啊
好不好
你看 連指指
不過這個是 那個
太太那邊的啦
所以是算 那個
嗯 就是 姻親的
故障 你看這個
看得有點遠
喔
所以 所以還是會要來問我
他在問我說這是真的嗎
但是假的
然後呢我就跟他說
我就跟他說把他摺一下
沒辦法摺
我說
詐騙阿別被騙了
但是詐騙阿怎麼可能真的
就只是真的
只是真的
很多啦齁
這很煩
沒事去加人家
我們的大頭貼都寫了
沒空失去你了好不好
各位沒空失去你
然後有人不只冒充我
冒充小編
你看我們知道封鎖了一堆小編
封鎖了一堆小編
封鎖超多的
很好玩齁
好啦
直播數以至一樣喔
他只要最高支付暖行人數
你這話跟強勢左右
各位自己看一下
上週中獎名單呢
四季操作啊
挑的股票大概主力說
做多跟多空配對
這也可以
我覺得這個也蠻好的
做多空配對啦市場大跌大很多很安心喔感謝小哥叫我們這招挑出表情可以自己調的就太棒了 可以啊配對好不好
各位你配對配得好
你有可能就怎麼樣
你有可能就是
多的也賺空的也賺嘛
就像我今天我為什麼要做這個呢
為什麼要做
為什麼要做波羅威
為什麼
他是一個多頭型態啊
各位你們自己看你這多多頭啊
跌破上升月線耶
不是個買點嗎對不對
然後呢這個
處置他已經準備進入下半段了
真的是買點啊
好不好明天再殺我再買
明天再殺我再買
請問南亞科目前多少可以接
跌到10塊你勇敢接
然後沒跌到10塊之前
我不知道我覺得蠻恐怖的
接都跟你講秋天了你還要接
秋天了你還要接
股票是個造山運動呢
有沒有它是不是造山運動
你不覺得這個很像那個嗎
很像當年的航海王嗎
你看像不像
對不對
像不像
超像
星星掛了嗎
沒有啦星星之後就會彈了啦
星星會彈啦
你等著看吧
我現在開始
我要開始要反過來了
反過來嘍
我原本是
那個買南電空星星
講明天
星星再跌
南店長我要反過來
我要反過來
好不好
我這樣反過來做了齁
這很好玩
你可以這樣配
做配
很有意思
再來
小哥教學課程
分享主治股超值真的超實用
每次照著邏輯進場
搭配主力籌碼背書
比樂透銀錢機率還高
今晚期待處置股軟體趕快上架
希望能看到更多進階的功能與細節分析
帶領大家掌握更多貨利益
真的啦 這比勒透音錢
真的
好好學啦 好好學 你去搭配一下
那你也可以用全證做
假如他有全證可以用全證做 因為畢竟他時間都蠻短的
那時間呢大概就是五六天 有時候兩三天就出場
像我今天這個 我還做當衝
波羅威跟環宇我還做當衝
波羅威也衝 環宇也衝
啊這兩個一衝
還不錯喔 所以盤中我們都一直在注意到有沒有什麼機會
有沒有什麼機會可以來做那個
雙刀的
盤州我們一直在做那個
哪些股票有適合做雙刀
要有適合做雙刀呢
我們就兩邊下
兩邊下呢就會比較安心
好不好 比較安心
那我們實際上是有在下單
有在下單的
有在下單當然就是會有賺有賠啊
至少告訴你說什麼樣很容易賠
啊什麼比較容易賺
那現在覺得這個
這個蠻
處置戰法算是
蠻好賺的
那之後呢
大盤呢有可能會
有一個蠻大的修正
這個修正可能也
還沒有結束
這修正呢
可能也還沒有結束
所以呢這個
那把盤這樣修正下去喔
欸 有一個東西就蠻有意思的喔
喔 有個東西呢 給各位看一下
有個東西呢 叫可轉載
可轉載這裡喔 這邊我們有
有發一個 這是公開的
欸 公開的啦 公開的
喔 這個元大
元大發行的元大的資料
那給各位看個東西啊
這叫做CBS
這公開的喔 公開的
各位呢你可以上我的PB去
下載來看
這原大的
這裡
各位歡迎去原大開悟
這原大的
歡迎去原大開悟
那他這個CBS
CBS這樣子
我們來看一下從最小價格到最高的
你看一下
這邊有很多
然後這邊是他的年期
他這個數字
這個數字呢
呃
他意思說
你只要花這些錢喔就可以買一張CBS那買一張CBS他的禁止呢大概大概都是多少都是10萬所以呢你可能花個400塊有10萬塊
花個1000塊有
1000塊不到有10萬塊價值
那400塊有10萬塊價值相當於
他的槓桿也是
槓桿呢
槓桿是兩
欸幾倍啊
槓桿是
250倍
250倍喔
欸槓桿250倍啊
你有250倍槓桿
這麼誇張的槓桿
但是沒有250倍槓桿的風險
啊400塊
你就賭集園一個春天
啊
這一年啊
這一年有噴的話
400塊可以賭一個春天
欸400塊欸
400塊生一年欸
400塊玩9個月餒
對不對
你有沒有看到
400塊玩9個月
這9個月極元要噴出去
對不對
極元
這個名字
對不對
極元
噴出去的話
各位你想想看
這個
噴出去
那這一檔
可轉再噴出去
那這種噴呢
他有時候
有時候呢
這種噴有時候
他的倍數很誇張
我們有看過那種噴兩三百倍的
好
啊這以前有多少呢
這以前對你而言
你自己想想看啊
你過年的時候
你的
那個
呱呱樂有沒有刮的比這些多
對不對
你過年呱呱樂有沒有刮比這些多
你呱呱呱樂
爽一下子
做善事啦做善事
做善事我們講的應該是你
你是想做善事啊你不是為了爽
這個除了做善事外爽那一下子
可能就是
沒筆就一兩分鐘就沒了
對不對
但是你買這些CBS
你是有機會玩
一年的對不對有機會玩一年的
有機會玩一年
然後呢
喔
這些價格目前還不一定很便宜
那有一天它可能變得超便宜
哪一天呢哪一天就是在崩盤那一天它就會變得很便宜那除了崩盤那一天變得很便宜那有些標的呢我們還可以來做什麼
我們還可以來做這個
動態避險
那什麼叫動態避險
這個化碳5呢
他就是一個適合做動態避險的標的
就是我們可以買CBS
然後呢用期貨來做這個動態避險
多外避險就是
你就上面空在底下補這樣子
上面空底下補
就這樣子
好
各位CBS頂多就歸零而已
好不好
不用擔心
你不用太糾結
頂多歸零
那有沒有可能常歸零
對 常常歸零
但是你至少有很長一段時間
可以陪著他
一大大行情
好
這是這個
我們可轉載呢
未來的課呢會教各位
就是我們去看一下最近的一些標的啊
那可轉載進階課呢就是
讓你看一下
什麼叫動態避險
動態避險我覺得很好玩
其實我
我是沒時間的
不然我真的覺得動態避險真的是
各位你好好學
他是一個不會讓你賠錢
動態幣險會賠就是
就怎麼樣 就股票沒動
好不好
所以動態幣險你不能選台灣大這種
這種
這種牛皮股
你選這種牛皮股
他就不能做動態幣險
除了這種牛皮股以外
其實很多都很適合做動態幣險
那動態幣險就是
你可以做無腦當衝
什麼叫無腦當衝
就是
你根本不用看盤
早上出門前把那個
買賣價位全部掛出去
你就出去
有三碗水
回來再看成交就好
那你一邊爬山你也可以一邊看成交
有成交你還可以繼續掛單
沒成交就沒事
這是萬筆錢
好啦
然後呢
今天有這個籌碼K線的優惠
有需要的可以購買
13個月
高生理處置課
3月26號
欸這個我們好像開3堂而已喔
我們只有開3堂而已喔
各位有興趣的
那個
可以來上啦
嗯這個
很有意思
那
我們
有些案例呢
我們會提早說那反正是量很大的我可能會做什麼就像那個新跟藍店我就跟你講了嘛已經跟你講了這有些案例比較大的
像那個
欸 環宇 KY
我覺得我可能還會再找一次再做一次
環宇 KY 也會再找一次做
會找一次做
好啦 那處置神器呢
會幫助你怎麼樣
預測明天這個處置的股票
然後呢 帶你找到交易機會
我們可以看一下一些雙刀戰法
雙刀戰法很好用
真的好用
然後看這個平均漲率
快看統計啦
這統計 你看喔
這儲置其實
第四天以後
他的就比較偏多了
比較偏多
沒有買儲置神器交易設計表怎麼做
你去報名那個
1月份的課程
1月份課程我們就有交了
因為分課程我們就教那個一色表怎麼做
就
欸 我們是褚之神器不是褚之王喔
不是褚之王 褚之王不是我的
好 我們神器裡面有
雙刀戰法 哇 這是雙刀戰法這個是
喔 這是獨創的喔
好 來交易筆記本 各位有興趣可以訂閱啦
交易筆記本的
這個 優惠券在這裡
喔 優惠券
喔 有需要可以看
好啦 假如筆紙本
穩定
蠻多穩定的
好
那最後呢 喜歡今天直播
歡迎按讚訂閱喔 留言觀看心得
我們抽景品娃娃跟軟體
欸 今天可以抽這個
好
喔
夾樂福的
那個
SRuby
喔SRuby啊
今天可以抽這一隻
要怎樣才能跟小哥吃頓飯
呃吃頓飯喔
就是
呃
來上個十年課吧
上十年課
就蠻面熟了
就可以吃飯了
我們那個我們
訂閱四年也都會請
請學恩吃飯的齁
哇上次訂閱資料我們捲一堆
之後再有再找機會再請各位吃啊
好啦
好
這是我在那
那個 我就好像長
長期的新幹線假的嘛
那是盧米
好 那我們
哇 我們這次
那個處置神器喔
低波的我們就算日本娃娃
大概把我的庫存全部清光還不夠
下禮拜我要去 又要去日本假了
下禮拜要帶
喔 下禮拜二我就沒辦法直播了
下禮拜要帶我媽
去賞音了
喔 這個
感謝賢慧的太太
這個放行
放行喔
讓我這次跟我媽同房
同一間房間
我大概這個
哇
想起上回
跟媽媽一起睡已經是
幾年前的事了
大概
這快四十幾年了你知道嗎
四幾年了
四幾年前是
這次要出國跟團
跟團
所以各位呢 這個有機會
有機會遇到我
因為我們是跟團的
因為帶媽媽出國跟團比較方便啦
但是我們有一天自由行
自由行就在東京賞音啦
各位在東京的朋友
這個有機會還是會遇到的
那東京賞音就很簡單啦
就找幾個公園
叫個Uber就到了
好 叫Uber就到了
哪一團
欸 我們這一團滿便宜的
三萬多塊而已
不是什麼高級團
三萬多塊
什麼旅行家的嘛
好像旅行家的
就是在義王找的
好 媽找的
去阿布去日本自家
我們這是跟團啊
帶阿布去
我是覺得
那個什麼
下飛機到處機場那段路
就已經覺得路途遙遠
下飛機到出機場
不會啦
那個你
你自駕的話你就
那個人會來
你在機場的
他會來機場
旁邊找你
然後你就去那個人
他們會有接摩車來接你
接摩車來接你
哦
小哥說的崩盤該不會是哦崩盤欸上次出國崩了一大段欸這是下禮拜二出國
來下禮拜二出國先跟我講
上次出國從這裡開始崩
3月2號
看WBC
2號300點
700點
1400點
嚇死了
上次出國崩了一大段
從35500
崩到這裡
哇塞不能三千點
加起來
跟阿牧旅遊會操懷嗎
其實不大喜歡
不要啦 我就知道好好跟媽媽出去玩
用手機看看就好了
不過我喜歡跟團坐遊覽車
跟團坐遊覽車超好睡的
有夠好睡
可以睡
萬一跟我同團
聽到我的呼聲就不好意思
不好意思 不好意思
主力出國 台股沒人熟
台股看起來也是個秋天啊 你自己看
看起來也是個秋天
所以要找 找股票避險啊 好不好
各位啊 找股票避險一下
喔 要找股票避險
喔 你的手上不能存存多單
喔 你要跟 這個 要嘛跟
對不對 跟楊英翔大哥一樣
買個put
要嘛你手上一定要有些空單來避險
好不好
避險
那個被套該怎麼辦
被套反彈找機會出就好了
反彈找機會出啊
他又不是每天跌
那個又沒有每天跌啊
對不對
你看今天都到這裡了
反彈到月線上你還不賣賣
對不對
反正月薪帳你就可以賣啊
反彈找機會出啦
忘掉你的成本好不好
誰記得成本誰痛苦
喔
忘掉你的成本
找機會出一出
唉呦十全都好強喔
十全這個我覺得回答不夠
回答不夠
613有夏天嗎
喔夏天啊這創高一定夏天啊
創高肯定是夏天
秋天的反彈任賠真的反彈任賠廖一如要被關了啦明天聽牌了好不好
明天聽牌
聽牌
尹薇是聽牌股
明天漲多了
聽牌了
尹薇明天是有機會被關的喔
好就這樣
來來來
這裡
哎呦 可轉載入門不是基礎班的
進階班了 好不好 進階班
台北廠 來來 給各位看喔
我們進階班這裡這裡這裡
進階這裡
我們有台中4月10號 高雄4月12
台北4月18
台中4月10 高雄4月12
可轉載教你
牛熊進階13教育什麼
啊這個可轉載進階課我們就講比較快了
因為出階課還要解釋很多科傳載的內容
然後進階課我們就講的比較細了
好
只要上課 換各位加一下
呃 換各位不是加一下 換各位猜一下
好啊這個答對送軟體
呃 就是你
號碼有中的話就送軟體
那我們就看誰比較前面喔
小秘書
小秘書抽喔
你看我的 我的那個
我的廣告都是旅遊
人生以旅遊為目的
賺的錢都花在旅遊身上就好了
什麼名牌 名表
都是帶不走的
好不好 帶不走齁
你有看到人家那個
看你微笑 然後帶個
帶個名表走嗎
沒有嘛 對不對
帶個名牌包包走嗎
沒有啦
都沒有好不好
你都站不走 只有回憶帶著走好不好
只有回憶帶著走所以呢 旅遊
他就是個回憶好不好
所以這次呢 這個感謝太太放行
可以帶我媽
出國 喔 因為我爸爸在家
沒有人顧著
所以我們家這次呢 4個小孩帶媽媽出國
喔 就這樣子
好
來 10號 12號 10號 12號中獎
最後勒這個各位記得要多多的去旅行啦多多去旅行有賺錢就去旅行啦
不用
名牌買一個就好了 名牌包買一個就好了
不要買十個名牌包
有事嗎 你是無功還是怎樣
十個名牌寫十個名牌包是怎樣
只有有那麼多肩膀要背嗎
不用好不好
把錢花在旅遊身上
让自己住的好 过得好
那个体验呢 体验是无价的
好不好 体验是无价
有空 有时间多带你
爹娘多带你父母出去玩
好不好 我们
那个前年
我记得
前年呢 我还有带我爸妈去
合掌村赏银
前年哦 带我爸妈去合掌村赏银
去年呢 我爸爸呢 就跌倒了
就住院跌倒 就不大會走了
然後呢 我們還是帶我媽媽去北海道賞英
今年呢 我爸爸只能在家裡了
那我們還是帶我媽媽去東京賞英
他們只要可以走 我就帶他們出去
那不能走就沒辦法了
所以跟各位講 這個可以帶著走 趕緊帶
好不好 趕緊帶著走
前幾天看到一個新聞
那個有個老師
為了去賞風嗎 辭職
對 就是這樣 你知道嗎
就是這樣 我以前為了賞音 我也辭職啊
我在201年就辭了
我說 我
我要看個音畫還不行
他說為了受教權 你不能出國
我說我出國 我就想春天跟秋天出國
不行 你只有夏天跟冬天才能出國
那夏天熱的要死
對不對 我當然想春天跟秋天出國嘛
好啦 沒關係 就不要交出了
就那個 那個
辭去教理化 改教理財
那現在就 人生就比較自由一點啦
至少 可以 我至少我是
除了疫情以外
我是每年都有帶我媽出去賞贏的啦
好啦
以上
下周帶媽媽去大環商業
很好
欸 我建議你
其實你假如是自住行的話
有些熱門景點可以不用去
有些熱門景點人太多了
其實日本的櫻花到處都是
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:10:00 起〕